hello everyone this game was played in
2010 World Team Championship and I
remember the first time I saw this game
I thought to myself man this guy really
has style and the guy I'm talking about
a sacar Nakamura this game he's playing
against Boris Gelfand and Boris Gelfand
in 2010 he was extremely strong he was a
sixth time he played in the candidates
and actually in 2011 he won the
candidates tournament and he in 2012 he
played against two Viswanathan Anand for
the world championship title and well it
was a very close match out of 12 games
it was 6 to 6 in the end but he lost in
the playoffs and gelfand also won the
2009 World Chess Cup so we could
probably say that this was guest on the
edits at his strongest so let's see how
this game went Hikaru Nakamura is black
and what is going on in white we have d4
by elephant Knight to f6 c4 g6 we have
an ID to c3 Bishop to g7 he car was
Saint favorite the Kings Indian defense
we have E for d69 to f3
hikaru castles Bishop to e2 key 5 gets
on castles Knight to c6 d5 Knight to e7
night to d2 and now 98 we have b4 and
this is always a theme in the Kings
Indian defense of white will expand on
the Queen side and black will go for the
attack on the Kings side we have F 5 by
Hikaru we have a c5 by guess one Knight
to f6
we have f3 f4 Bucky Carl Knight to c4
now g5 by Hikaru and now a four by
elephant and already you can see how
white expanded very nice so here on the
Queen side and the key card will
continue with this plan going for the
attack on the Kings side
he plays Knight to g6 we have Bishop to
a3 and he can replace wrote the f7 key
car wants to get this rook out of this
f8 where the bishop is hearing and also
it will help with the defense of the of
the seventh rank so
b5 by guess 1 and we have D captors on
z5 we have Bishop captures on c5 and now
h5 by DeCaro
we have a five and now Figaro pushes g4
and the gas and also pushes b6 we have G
3 into H 1 and our Bishop the f8 key car
would like to exchange this dark squared
bishop we have a d6 bug a son and a
captors and v6 and in this position well
this could be considered kind of a
critical position of the game in this
position gate son plays a bishop to g1
he could have played something like a
captors and b6 and go for the exchange
of rooks and after seek after sandy 6
root 2 d1 by gelfand but after nice eh
eh this would be perfectly okay for
black and well guess I'm decided not to
go for this so after he cover plate a
captures on b6 here guys went put this
Bishop on g1 and he caught up late night
to h4 the engine doesn't really like
this nitrate for mu but so like I always
say I don't really care what the engine
likes I like the move and well garrison
didn't realize in what kind of danger he
was and he plays rook to e1 and this
allows her hikaru one of the one of the
greatest combinations have seen in
modern chess he plays Knight captures on
g2 and well obviously the Knight has to
be captured he is attacking the rook of
any move to play but capturing the
knight would be simply wrote that one
and then he simply retreats with the
night to h4 and as this is actually
playable Blackwood to be better here
because those King side pawns are so far
advanced but this one finds the
interesting idea get some place a D
captures on c7 he wants to exchange
Queens and the seeker went for this for
example if he cover plate Queen casters
on d1 rook captures on d1 now key card
has to get this night out of harm's way
for example nice to h4 we have h
captures from g3
FK after some g3 and a captures on v6
and this would be excellent for wise
actually this would be winning for white
so this is actually the position gets
and so when you play the D captures on
c7 but hákarl has another idea here and
this is where it all starts he kind of
plays Knight captures anyone he he's
given up a whole Queen here and of
course the Queen cannot be captured if
the queen is captured and simply upon 2
G 2 will be checkmate so like I said he
called offers his queen and as it cannot
be captured guess and plays Queen
captures anyone he captures the knight
and he here Hikaru continues with his
attack he plays g2 with check only
movies King captures on g2 and now rook
the g7 check so he plays King 2 H 1 of
course not pink 2 f1 then Bishop - 3
would be crushing and on King 2 f2 then
Bishop to c5 also crushing so King to H
1 pretty much only moves and here if you
can replace another fancy move
he plays Bishop to h3 give it a trying
to trying to sacrifice the screen for
the second time this game and again the
Queen cannot be captured because simply
Bishop to g2 will be checkmate
so this has to be stopped and get some
place Bishop to f1 but now he car again
finds a very very nice move and a very
creative move he plays Queen to d3 now
trying to give up the Queen this way
he's offering the Queen here and of
course the bishop cannot capture the
Queen is the Bishop captures and simply
Bishop to G to checkmate
finishes the game but there is also the
threat of Queen captures an s3 here if
Queen captures an s3 Bishop to g2 then
Queen captures and g2 will be checkmate
well okay if for example even Bishop
captures and it's really then Queen
captures on f3 Bishop has the block and
this will be checkmate so again the
Queen cannot be captured so this has to
be stopped and get someplace nice to e5
capturing the pawn and now he's
protecting f3 so he's stopping this
threat and he's also attacking the Queen
with the knife now
and here another brilliant multi-car
with sacrifices it tries to sacrifice a
screen for the fourth time he plays
Bishop captures an f1 and now again even
this knight cannot capture the Queen as
bishop the g2 will be checkmate again
and I'm sure at this moment the elephant
was pretty pissed for putting this
Bishop to g1 as this move allowed all of
these tactics and I don't know if this
probably isn't one of the son's favorite
games so garrison captures the bishop
Queen captures on f1 and Hikaru captures
the knight Queen captures on c3 and now
Hikaru is threatening to capture the
night here and also his threatening to
play a bit captures on a5 here on double
in the pawns and well this will be quite
winning so guess one tries another idea
he plays rook to c1 attacking the Queen
and preparing to promote this spawn into
a queen of the zone so he colleges
capture screen captures on e5 we have
seat c8 queen broadcasters and chroot
cast resin c8 and Quinta e6 and in this
position body hasn't resigned after well
the rook is attacked he has to move it
and that for something like Brooke to
see one simply even bishop kept the
captures on a5 will be completely
winning he covers up a piece and while
he has this strong A&B porn ready to
push and what this is completely over so
yeah like I said I remember the first
time I saw this game I was like yeah
this this dude has hairstyle and I
really enjoyed this game every time I
see it I do hope you enjoyed it as well
and as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here yeah that's it a
very nice game against some against
someone who will who will the next year
window window candidates tournament and
the play for the championship title so
yeah very nice game by Cara Nakamura
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon